a story in five words
[Applause]
five words CNN sees message in Subway
Smith is tight-lipped he was spotted
today by CNN going to Subway for lunch
picking up a sandwich leaving and not
saying a word Jack Smith going to Subway
today is a message to Donald Trump
Donald Trump tries to intimidate people
he tries to bully people he tries to
scare you away that was Jack Smith with
no words and a simple five dollar Sub in
his handset I'm here I'm not going to
yeah the imagery was uh was intentional
in spoken
yeah those were um CNN hosts
well you heard them all those people at
that table and not one saying what the
[Laughter]
we spotted him outside his Subway and
then he got a sandwich and then he left
you know this powerful message I know
what the message was the message was
look Donald I only eat one of these
that's that's the problem with they're
doing wall-to-wall coverage on this yeah
so like those poor bastards have nothing
else to add
because there's nothing that new that's
happened but the network makes them do
it so they're like okay uh the sandwich
he didn't say anything which must mean
like like he he's brave for going to get
a sandwich do you think like Trump's
gonna be there and do what it doesn't
make any sense they know it doesn't make
any sense but they're on a good time
chance Trump would be there well you
know Joe you are the sandwich expert and
as people have noticed at home you do
look like Jared from Subway
[Laughter]
do there
[Applause]
I did a story just for you
before you laughed too hard he's been
reading that on Twitter for 10 years he
didn't write that joke
Twitter
for a decade it's because it's true I
know
Jared wishes they had no cash bail back
in uh
[Laughter]
what were you I don't know I lost my
train of thought
sandwiches I had a point to make what
what's the message you want to do
another Trump joke
uh no I was gonna no no actually I was
gonna actually say something in the
other direction uh uh Smith this is what
I as I was reading about this story this
is what I find crazy so he is appointed
to oversee these uh investigations about
January 6 against Trump fine whatever
his wife
made a glowing documentary about
Michelle Obama that's right I don't
understand when conflict of interest
comes into play anymore if I as a hoagie
store owner Joey Rose's 174 Rivington
Street
if I is a hoagie store owner or go to
jury duty and they go the guy the
defendant is a hoagie store I know I am
immediately sent out I am not I can't
qualify it anymore I don't understand
how this there's not a conflict of
interest yeah I think we're gonna from
now we're just gonna say you're an hso
he's an hso but you didn't know that all
right that that was a terrible joke I
just made that's okay yeah but yeah do
you have any thoughts on what I said
though I was really not really
so what he does is he asks you a
question then when you answer he stops
listening
for the next question yeah Charles uh is
it their fault I mean we're in this
business uh if you do one thing as as
Joe was saying wall to wall or maybe it
was cat I can't remember wasn't
listening yeah
is what happens
yeah I know how it kind of I mean when
you read it right I'm fascinated to see
the what special counsel brings for and
then Dana Bash yeah the imagery was
intentional and spoke volumes it's like
the smoking weed at an art like an art
gallery somewhere like you know or they
see like uh you know the the a figure in
a sandwich themselves look at that but
they have to be careful of CNN because
they're they're propensity to elevate
people in this idolatry right uh
Governor Cuomo he's going to be the next
guy next president and then Stormy
Daniels attorney he is so amazing you
see the way he walks Trump must be
quivering right now I mean they do this
this guy is the next Stormy Daniels
lawyer whatever the hell his name is
they're going to elevate this guy's
gonna be Joe Biden's number one
Contender come next November for the
Democratic nomination you can bet though
stormy's had her share of footlongs
oh
I mean he said it
blaming the black guy
hey look like the black guy you're the
Jew you get to defend him
oh you're getting a chapter in my book
my lesson I had a joke about
Contemporary Art and I'm not going to
say it now because basically you just
said it it reminds me of going into an
art gallery just like over analyzing
something but but also uh Charles makes
a good point and I I have to say we have
to be fair in Balance when you find
somebody that is on your side you have a
tendency to do that and I'm sure we've
done that here and but they CNN they're
like they they go into these short-term
like romances and then they're and then
they go you don't hear from story Stormy
Daniels you don't hear from Michael
avenatti anymore you don't hear then
who's the lawyer for Trump that's always
on CNN now Steve Cohen yeah yeah Michael
Michael Cohen like they hated him before
but now they love him it's so funny that
that that's how it works what's scary
though is CNN's audience and they're
just sitting there taking it in and
we're the ones pointing out how
ridiculous this is and laughing about it
but this is a major News Network that's
watched all over the world and their
word is truth to many and it's just
all over the world but only in airports
hotels
I like that the the message is like look
at this guy you know he's shooting from
the hip he's secure he's just Waltzing
in the subway getting a hoagie and
leaving yeah this couldn't have been
more orchestrated right he's got a team
of people behind him this is like when
you see anytime you see a celebrity yeah
go like this to the paparazzi outside of
a restaurant oh they got the airport
they went to the restaurant on purpose
yeah because that's where the paparazzi
is yeah and this this to me just felt
like that so I don't maybe it is a
message I don't know what the message is
but what do you think the message could
be I don't know
to be honest I've two doubt
yeah it wasn't lying
he was I'm like little because he needs
time to start thinking of what he's
going to say no no I'm thinking about
what I'm gonna eat
when you start doing a segment on food
I'm I'm done I'll just start thinking
about what I'm eating you know what this
this show went right to your head you
used to care you used to
you stick red eye
I cared less all right coming up are
humans ready to take their shot with a
sexy box hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else